[Music]
kamilla Kibeho just dropped two new
songs and fans think one of them is all
about Shawn Mendes but I know for sure
about love is that you never come out of
it the same after dropping a bunch of
hints on Instagram the singer officially
confirmed she's releasing a second album
and to celebrate she shared a brand new
single liar oh and the brand new video
for her single shameless
[Music]
in the video Camilla dances her ass off
casually walks down the middle of an
empty city street takes five in a
confessional box hits the club and even
levitates totally normal
[Music]
kamilla also happens to have eight local
Ike's on standby who would dance with
her in perfect harmony get it like fifth
harmony okay moving on in a statement
from Camila she explained the meaning
behind her new album quote these songs
are basically the story of my life the
past couple years and the stories I've
accumulated I knew for a long time I
wanted my album to be called romance
because these stories are about falling
in love
naturally fans took to social media like
a moth to a freakin a flame to weigh in
on the video and a lot of the 22 year
olds Twitter followers speculated that
the track and this era of romance could
be about Shawn
[Music]
one fan pointed to the lyrics writing
quote Wow shameless is such a bob but
the lyrics we're all agreed this song is
about Shawn right others were quick to
notice that Shawn shared this screenshot
to his insta story yeah he's playing
shameless and according to his choice of
emojis his mind is bolon of course Shawn
and kamila have been pretty tight-lipped
about their rumored romance but that
hasn't stopped them from flaunting some
serious PDA we're talking tonsil hockey
people and in the October issue of Elle
magazine at Camilla opens up about why
she's keeping their love private quote
love is the most sacred precious thing
to me I want to always feel like my love
is between me and that person and never
belonging to anyone else and when the
mag asked whether she thinks the secrecy
has created more buzz about her in the
21 year old singer she responded quote
they can speculate but at the same time
we are going to live our own lives enjoy
it and fall for each other like nobody
is watching that is how I want to live
she added I want it to be mine and his
that's why I'm so tight-lipped about it
because I want to protect it o M G I'm
sorry
fall for each other like nobody is
watching okay if your heart is exploding
raise your hand just me okay of course
we'll be right here to keep you in the
know on all things Shawn Mila so make
sure to keep it locked right here on e t
until next time I'm Hallie Stevens bye
for now
[Music]